hey on today's show we're going to be
talking about honeymooning at your
in-laws house
how to have hard conversations with your
kids we're going to talk to somebody
who's struggling because their brothers
and sisters
don't have time for and we're going to
talk to an awesome wife and mother
who just wants to be perfect for her
husband while he's deployed
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey oh it's john and this is the dr john
deloney show
where we're taking your calls about life
your calls about your relationships your
calls about your parents your marriages
all of it goal of this show is to help
you rethink
re-examine reconsider your lives how you
talk to yourself how you talk to your
kids
how you talk to your neighbors your kids
teachers
how you talk to your folks i talk to
those who love
those who you don't love right and on
this show we may talk about love we may
talk about loss we may talk about family
issues heartbreak
or we may talk about one of my favorite
things in the entire world
and that is dads who change
dads who say i don't care so much about
the next promotion i care about
hugging my kids i care about
looking my wife in the eye looking
people that i love in the eye
and saying i'm here for you dads who
decide
you know what i'm gonna stop running
from my childhood pain i'm gonna
reconnect
we may talk about dads because dads can
change
family systems when they say no more
let's get reconnected
we're going to talk about all of it on
this show so anyway whatever's going on
in your home
in your heart in your head give me a
call at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291 or you can email
me at ask
john ramsey solutions.com ask john
ramseysolutions.com
let's go to the phones let's go to erica
in
pittsburgh erica good morning how are we
doing
i'm doing well how are you fantastic
what's going on in pittsburgh
pennsylvania today
uh not a whole lot um i'm actually just
calling you because i have a question
i'm just wondering how i can get my
husband motivated
to put off his school loan so we can
move out from his parents house
uh oh how long have you been living in
his parents house
um it's actually only been a month and a
half
you're and you're already done with it
yes
yes so man that's awesome so
how is it going um i mean that hasn't
been like too bad
there's been a few instances where
you kind of like cross paths with the
in-laws that kind of makes me
uncomfortable
we're like they're trying to put their
input in and
it's really hard to like tell them you
know kind of keep out
it's our situation are you guys so we're
kind of like
just really stuck at this point but it
is their house so they kind of get to
tell you what they want to right
yeah but it's your marriage and it's
real
frustrating right yes exactly how long
have you been married
ah a month and a half oh so you went
straight from your honeymoon
from the like to your
in-laws house yeah exactly is there any
way to
kill the buzz of a honeymoon a coveted
honeymoon
like moving in with your mother-in-law
so tell me about this
this awesome guy you married you love
him you're living in his mom's house
and he doesn't want to pay stuff off
tell me about that
yeah um so he actually started paying
off his school loan in the beginning of
january
um but it's kind of to the point right
now where we only owe
about six seven thousand rnas and
obviously between the both of us we have
enough to pay it off like
right this second um i'm not really sure
why
i know what this is he doesn't want to
move does he
i don't think he wants to move
he likes his mama's house and he likes
his live-in wife
man this dude likes being having it all
the same time huh
yeah yeah so do y'all have a plan
did y'all when you moved in to his mom's
house did y'all have a
we're gonna do this for six months we're
gonna do this for in your mind 45 days
and then we're out of here what was the
plan moving in
um well we actually didn't set a
specific date it was just kind of like
well we're going to work on this school
loan once we get the school loan paid
off
then we're going to save a little bit um
to either get a down payment for a house
or to find somewhere to rent
uh but we do talk about it last month
and we said we would like to pay off a
school loan by
november that way we have some time to
save up
but there hasn't been a whole lot of
movement
in the school loan so it sounds like you
need to address this as a values
conversation not as a math problem
not as a tactical solution but as a who
are we going to be
and where are we going to be
conversation like a
like an emotional and a geographical
conversation not a student loan issue
i think you're probably right i think he
likes being there and
i think maybe he doesn't even like being
there but there's parts of his
um amygdala system
that feels safe there and he's got to
grow the heck up
when once he moves out right and he has
grown up because he got married he has
grown up because he's graduated college
but there's a part of him that's not
ready to grow up and that's that time
and what i would do if i was you is
take him out somewhere you'll have a
planning retreat of some sort
and let him know we're moving out in
three months
or i want to that's that's probably a
little bit strong for a values
conversation
let him know it's my preference that we
start
our life together by ourselves and our
own place even if we have to
grind it out in a one bedroom apartment
and live on love and
and and but if it was up to me we would
be out of there
in three months total so we'd be out of
here in a month and a half
what is your thoughts on how long we're
going to live here and make it less
about the
the debt part and more about where are
we going to be and who we're going to be
because here's the deal once you decide
okay we're going to be out of here in
five months we're gonna be out of here
in
three months then you know he knows
we're a debt-free couple we're a couple
that's not gonna have these
chains wrapped around our necks as we
start our life together
and so we need to go ahead and get that
paid off because that's gonna be the
first thing we do
and that way it takes away the whole
that
takes away the hook of my mom's house is
i've got this student loan hanging out
there that's off the table
it's a values conversation and while
you're there you can talk about
what your home is going to be like um
what the next five years are going to be
like
what grad school is going to look like
if that's what you can have a broader
values-based conversation
did you all do pre-marital counseling oh
we did not
you didn't so i would recommend doing
that now
it would be called i guess immediately
after marriage counseling or
post-marriage counseling but i think
having somebody walk alongside you guys
and give you good questions given you
give you good
exercises to do as a couple to begin to
build your
communication style as a couple why did
y'all get married
so soon how long did y'all date uh we
also were together for
about two and a half almost three years
and
i mean we honestly couldn't even decide
on a wedding date and finally we just
picked one and we're like
this is the one we're doing it we're
going for it and that was pretty much
why
so i i just said why'd you get married
so soon i said the wrong
thing let me ask let me rephrase it and
say
why did you get married or how did you
get married so loosey-goosey
it just you just said it perfect it
feels like y'all were just like um
okay and then we'll just do this and
then let's just do that there hasn't
been a lot of intentionality behind it
right tell me about that is it because
of kovit is it because of
the world usually weddings are a thing
and getting married is a thing and it
feels like y'all are just like uh you
want to go to sonic
or we can go to wendy's it's like ah
let's go to wendy's that's what it feels
like we
yeah we both are kind of just
go with the flow kind of people um we
didn't even have a we didn't even really
plan on having a big wedding to begin
with we just had our family
come over so it wasn't something like
the dates didn't really mean a whole lot
to us
we honestly were just all right this
sounds good we'll go with it
i don't know we didn't really have that
kind of conversation
so this is going to be something that is
a going to be a
wonderful attribute to you to as a
couple it's going to let you guys roll
with the flow
and when ups and downs in life come
y'all are going to be able to
morph and shift with with ease
and it's going to be a beautiful thing
and
this can be disastrous for you too
because you can both end up in a place
that neither of you wanted to be or
intended to be
and suddenly you blink your eyes and
it's seven years from now and you don't
know that dude then you don't even know
where you're living
and and and and so getting
some structure around your lives and
becoming more intentional
not in grabbing things more tightly but
being more intentional about your love
and relationship
and where you want to go and who you
want to be when you get there or who you
want to be on the way
is is something i'm looking i can't
recommend that enough for you to
okay and don't let that take the spirit
and and
uh flexibility of your relationship it
sounds beautiful and awesome
man if more couples were like man we
just love each other we're just gonna
get married
um but then you can also blink your eyes
and you're married and then
you are spending the first romantic few
months of your marriage
in your husband's old uh
high school bedroom right yeah and it
can get super
weird um yeah walking down the hallway
and running into your father-in-law
yeah right right um so yeah i would i
would
strongly recommend hook up with a man i
am not using the right words today
don't hook up with anybody other than
him find yourself
a a pre-marriage counselor let him know
hey we got married we've been together
for three years and we just want to
learn some skills
tell your husband that you want to to do
that see if he wants to be a part of
that
and then go have a visioning time with
him go have a
when are we moving out i want to move
out right today and that probably is not
going to happen but maybe three months
maybe five months sounds like you guys
have the money
and a part of that's going to be let's
go and write this check a part of that's
going to be
where do we want to live we can live
anywhere or what do we want to be doing
professionally
and start those values based
conversations there's that old cheesy
leadership line that's true which is if
you don't have any plans or goals
if you don't have any direction you're
surely going to end up there
and you're just at the mercy of where
that's going to be and i've just worked
with so many people over the years
and they are frustrated and exhausted
and beat down um because they end up in
a forest that they
never intended to to go to so good for
you sarah
i'm good for you erica good for you
erica you all are going to have fun
and it's going to be exciting and my
high fives are with you
i would like to hear how that
conversation goes how the visioning
conversation goes
call me back if you get a shot all right
let's go to sarah in grand rapids
michigan
sarah good morning how are you doing
good how are you
good i lost you there earlier i hope
you're doing well so tell me how i can
help this morning
okay so my son is five years old i got
married when he was one and a half
and then when he was three my husband
adopted him
but my question is how and when
do we tell our son
wow that's a great question thank you
for your trust here
um so who is his birth father
i'm just a random man okay
does does that random man know about
his son yeah okay and so that man has
chosen i don't to not be in his life in
any way shape form or fashion
yeah okay and so on his birth
certificate when your
now husband adopted him is that is his
name reflected on your son's birth
certificate
yes okay so i called again
i've i've got a team of counselors
across the country that i will check in
with
with sometimes when i know there's going
to be a challenging question or one that
i don't have
some direct experience with or that i
think i've got some opinions on but i
want to make sure i'm getting the right
wisdom and again
i checked with my good friend lynn
jennings what she does for a living is
have hard conversations with kids
and she talks about parental right
terminations and she talks about
abuse situations and she walks kids
through court processes and so she's a
savant when it comes to these things and
i actually sat down with her and said
hey walk me through
how we would imagine the situation here
and so
um there's several ways you can do this
none of which are going to be awesome
and none of which are going to be the
end of all things
but the what you don't ever want to do
when your son is
16 17 or 18 is have him turn around and
think
my mom lied to me right and so it's
you're a saint for even thinking about
this
um here were some some recommend
recommendations here are some ideas
one is wait until the child's old enough
to fully process
the emotions that are going to be there
if a a dad is present if a dad might
show back up in a situation which you
don't want to do for a five-year-old or
a six-year-old and there's actually some
children's books that help these
conversations along
you don't want them to get surprised in
this situation where it sounds like
birth date is 100 out of the picture
completely out of the loop
and your your child your son has a
awesome guy who's present in his life
who has adopted him who is fully
invested as his daddy
um that's not going to be the case and
so
the recommendation is 10 to 12 maybe a
little bit older
when you would sit down and have that
conversation but what i would recommend
is that you start planting seeds now
and what planting seeds looks like is
your new husband your
the father of this little boy the daddy
of this little boy
starts today and he may already do this
he starts telling him today
every day i am so grateful that i chose
you
that i chose to be your daddy
i'm so grateful i chose to be your dad
and he's going to do that every single
day
of that little boy's life and when you
talk about
his daddy you're going to talk about can
you believe that you are so
perfect and so wonderful and so loved
that your daddy chose you
god chose mommy and god chose daddy and
daddy chose
you and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna build up
a bank one year two year three years
five years six years worth of insight on
that little boy understanding that his
daddy chose him
so that one day when the conversation
happens and that when that conversation
begins
anybody can be a father anybody can
father a child
but very few men step up and become a
daddy and this guy chose to
then when your son understands that
disconnection when he start
understands asking questions and those
things that are natural and right and of
course they're gonna happen
but he will be tethered in deeply with
his
dad and then you're gonna have these
life experiences these developmental
things these
you know the spiritual bases all of
these are different and i would also
recommend when you decide to have this
conversation if it's something you're
gonna plan and not something that pops
back up
there are people like my friend lynn
there are people all over the country
who are
especially skilled at teaching little
kids
where they come from and why they come
from where they come from
and it depends on what life has been
like
for them what you know their spiritual
values if are they people of faith are
they
not um developmentally are they
so you know they're very mature 10 year
olds they're very immature 10 year olds
and they are excellent at breaking some
of these conversations in there and
letting kids
slowly and gently absorb and hear these
things at the same time know that
they're safe and tethered in
and so tell me about this guy that you
married is he awesome
yes does he love that little boy yes
that's awesome good for you and
good for freaking him good for him for
choosing your little boy
and choosing to become an extraordinary
dad tell me about your little boy
um he likes tractors he's
like music he's
just active rambling
so your little boy is a smiling fun
excited little boy he's got a daddy who
loves him
he's got a mommy who loves him
sarah i just want to honor your heart
when do i tell them how do i tell them
having hard honest conversations with
children is challenging
again in this situation every day he
needs to know
not only told but he needs to feel he
needs to see your eye contact he needs
to feel your touch
lots of touch on his face lots of touch
on his feet lots of hugs
but i want his dad this man who chose
him i want every day of his life
this guy to look your son in the eye and
say i'm so glad i chose to be your daddy
i get to be your dad and again 10
11 12 maybe a little bit older depending
on again developmental life things
you're going to sit down with an expert
who's gifted at talking to kids like my
good friend
dr lynn jennings and you're all going to
have that conversation together
and then it's going to be totally
natural for
your son to want to meet his birth dad
someday your son to want to reach out
your son's going to have questions about
why did my daddy not want me
i mean why did my original father what
was it about me
that made him not want to be around and
when he has those questions which are
natural and they are good and they are
understandable
he will be completely anchored and
tethered in to the fact that he is loved
by two parents who care for him
and two parents that choose to love him
every day
thank you for your heart sarah you're
awesome all right let's go to
um let's see here we could go to here
let's go to kate let's go to kate in
san diego california kate how are we
doing
just dandy how are you just dandy too
just dandy i love that all right so how
can i help what's going on
um i'm calling to ask for help
navigating relationships with my
married siblings uh oh all right so
bring it on
i'm 24 um and i'm the youngest of 10.
most of them most of them are married
and their priorities as they should be
are their spouses and children
um but i just get in this pretty regular
emotional battle between
feeling kind of lost in the shuffle
worthless and significant
um just like always back of the line and
then just you know kind of suck it up
kids like this is what happens
everyone's supposed to grow up and
have their own families then you just
have to you know
i guess just be prepared for whatever
comes your way
um how old are you 24. 24. you told me
that that's right
so you're 24 you've got 10 brothers and
sisters how old is the oldest one
um she would be 47
almost 48. 47 48. so she's was she a de
facto parent to you
yeah yeah she was 23 when i was born and
loved kids and
yeah i was kind of my second mom okay
and did you have a third mom and a
fourth mom too
and a fifth mom probably you know not
really
um mostly you know i i didn't even exist
when the first four of them graduated
high school so
um wow okay yeah i
you know i've had fairly good
relationships with a lot of them but for
most of them i don't really
i don't really know them other than
husbands and wives and
mothers and fathers i don't really know
them as well as just my brothers and
sisters
so they're as much uncles and aunts as
they are brothers and sisters really huh
in some ways yeah so painting a picture
of what you wish was going on what do
you wish was happening
um i guess i just i want to be friends
like when i was growing up i just had
this
i always wanted to be big enough you
know by the time i was in seventh grade
i was the only one left in the house um
and i just i would watch home videos and
i just wanted so badly to have been big
enough to just i guess experience life
with them
instead of coming up on the tail end and
just getting all the advice from the
mistakes and successes that they'd had
and
um and that's not really a fair picture
it's not like they never did anything
with me but um
but i at this point i just kind of feel
like i'm
sliding into their lives whenever they
have a second because they're busy right
they've got
careers and families and and i i'm
craving them just making time for me but
it's
not necessarily a fair ask but then i
just go into this tailspin of
of every little time that they say no
it's just like adding to this
list of rejection in my mind of you know
no you're not worth me taking away from
my family and i don't want them to take
away from their family
and i guess that's where my my struggle
comes i just don't know how to
i guess reconcile those two emotions of
i'm proud of you for being good spouses
and parents
and would never want you to be anything
less but i also just
i don't want to feel important enough
yeah where where else do you get
rejected where else have you been
rejected
put your family aside where else do you
experience rejection
you know i'm not really sure i you
experience rejection in school
do you get have rejection in your own
relationships or at work
not not really um i mean
it takes me like years to make friends
why is that at all
how come i i i really struggle with
spending time on relationships that i
don't see
being real
i guess or deep enough
so i i really just have a hard time just
going out to hang out with somebody if i
don't really
feel like they're going to be a really
true friend to me in the future
so you you called me can we go real can
we swan dive into the
into the deep waters for a minute um
why or where does
your judgment of your snap judgment of
you meet somebody you talk to them for a
few minutes and you immediately deem
you're not going to be someone that's
going to be worth my long term time and
you bail
where does that come from i have no idea
it's either a sense of superiority or
it's a sense of
fear of getting hurt at some point which
one do you think it is
there might be both um yeah i mean i
guess definitely both i feel like
i don't know if i would necessarily say
superiority but
i do get the
you know i have values and
things that i want to uphold and i i
know that i regularly
feel like if you're gonna be
trying to get me to not uphold those
values or if i feel like you're not
gonna be
respectful of them then i struggle with
that a lot
well as you should right those are your
values but this is a little bit deeper
when you meet somebody and decide you
know what you're probably not going to
be someone who i'm going to have
long-term experiences with that i'm not
going to we're probably not gonna
connect
a couple years from now so let's just
cut it off now that's a really great way
to keep you from getting hurt
relationally and it's a great way to
to keep you completely and totally
alone and so one of the greatest ways of
never getting hurt there is one surefire
way there's one surefire way of never
getting hurt and that's never having
really deep relationships with people
never choosing to go into deep
relationships with people because the
one guarantee
the price of admission for being a good
friend the price of admission for
falling in love
the price of admission for being a
connected family member
is hurt eventually something's gonna
hurt
and there's something about you and i'm
trying to get it i want you to to walk
me through this
there's something about you that is
fearful of getting hurt and it's easier
to be on the sidelines with the built-in
relationships that are
innate family and they need to be i'm
feeling this separation this gap
but also at the same time there's other
relationships that you could be
experiencing
that you have would enrich you that
would challenge you
and you just deem them on the front end
which protects you but also make sure
you're completely alone
yeah what are you worried about hurting
you
kate in san diego i guess
um i've always when i
when i do have friends i really only
have like a you know
one or two extremely good ones and
everybody else is just kind of there
um and both times
oh they just kind of disappear
and i you know the first one i was my
best friend when i was a kid and
um we were best friends for years and
then
she went to a different school and then
i moved away the next year and she
literally just stopped talking to me
um and then
the next one when i was in high school
and then i went to college and
after about a year
started happening her life and she did
the same thing almost and
recognized it and apologized later but i
guess they
are you a great friend why
i think so i hope so from my perspective
i would say yes but
that you're awesome that's not a i'm not
digging i'm just wondering are you a
great friend
yeah i i think i am yeah
and so what i want to tell you is you're
worth being 24 years old and have having
had more than just two good friends in
your lifetime
you are worth having i've got somebody
at my house
this week who i've known for 25 years
he's just crashing with us we think
differently
we live differently we act differently
we still relentlessly make fun of each
other
and we still relentlessly hold each
other accountable for
a core set of values
and he's one of a number of great
wonderful friendships that i've had that
fades and ebbs and flows
and is rich and is deep
but you're worth more than two
friendships and when it circles back to
your family
you're worth more than just hoping that
they will reach out and include you
you're worth including yourself you're
worth going to
their kids games and their kids events
and doing the things relationally
instead of sitting on the outside and
waiting for them to include you
you're a person of value enough that is
worth being around other people
your love is worth other people
experiencing
and that means risk relationships don't
start with comfort they start with risk
they start with hey will you be my
friend
or hey let's go hang out or man you're
weird or i don't like the way you say
that
or i don't like your language or or fill
in the blank but they all start with
risk
right i think i think that's where i
struggle though because i do take those
risks
and i you know i am included in their
family lives but i'm i'm asking my
brother to come
hang out with me for literally the first
time just us in
the two years that i've lived near him
and
the 10 years that i've been anywhere
near old enough to go hang out and
he can't take the time away from his
family sure like dude
three hours and what does he say when
you call
um well is it too long two-hour long
conversation of
really frustrating but it literally was
he's in the military they've got several
kids
and he's getting ready to play yeah um
and so to him
it was it literally it was a how dare
you put that on me
and can i tell you that i think that's
fair can i tell you i think that's fair
like everything in his life's about to
be upside down
and for sure what i would say is
friendship works two ways
brother and sisterhood works two ways
and you lift each other up when the
other person's down
and so instead of hey you owe me some
time together
it is you're about to deploy you're
about to be separated from your kids for
a year you're going to be in a situation
that you may or may not be safe
you're going to be away from your wife
i'm going to come insert myself and
start making meals
and mow your lawn and do groceries and
things like that
i've offered yeah well sometimes the
babysitter
so that they can go spend time together
i offer to babysit so that she can go
have time alone because she's about to
be with them
all day every day just by herself and
they don't take me up on it
and i i don't i truly i don't know what
else
of myself i can give without
just feeling again like i'm just lost
like i'm just constantly
here to make everything easier for you
but when i'm
almost depressed you can't be there i
can't call you
i can't
i truly i understand that they
they're about to go through a really
hard time again and again i don't want
to take him away from that at all
are you gonna miss your brother so much
yeah are you scared for him to go a
little bit yeah
are you scared for their marriage in a
relationship
um
not really i mean not scared for it not
that it's gonna break up but that's just
going to be hard right you know your
brother's going to be in pain right
yeah absolutely and so rest in that that
means you're awesome
and that doesn't mean that you fail it
doesn't mean you're a loser that means
that
man there's a lot going on and you did
the best you can sleep with a sound
heart and mind
you reached out and you did what you
could and that's that
does that make you lonely yeah does that
make it hard yeah
do you need to get other people in other
deep relationships in your life yeah
but that doesn't mean you failed
something that doesn't mean you're a
loser that doesn't mean that you're not
worth anything
that means you didn't want your
casserole and quite honestly he might
want your casserole maybe he doesn't
want to impose on you
and maybe his way of showing how much he
loves his little sister is to not let
her get hurt
or to not let her be mushed up into all
this
and it may just be showing up
or it may just be honoring him and say
cool sending him a letter
sending little gift bags to those kids
and doubling down on hard relationships
are going to be in your circle and
around you
and in your local environment
the sucky part of relational risk is
that sometimes it doesn't look like you
want it to look
and it's hard and i wish i had a pat
answer for you i really do kate
i wish i could just say oh just do these
three things that's not how
relationships work
but i do think stepping back and saying
did you try to reach out to your brother
you did man you tried to love him good
for you
but also stepping back and saying i've
had two relationships two friendships
over the course of my 24 years you sound
like a really kind person
you sound like a gifted person but you
also sound like a person who guards
himself very carefully
you sound like a person who is very
giving of themself
but is really hard when people don't
want that particular gift and that's
okay
but i want you to work really hard you
may have to get with
um a counselor you may have to get with
a pastor that you trust
get with some folks and
oh man i don't want to say this in a way
that can be heard
you've got to get yourself in a place
where
you can take relational risks and you
can enter into spaces
not for the roi of i want this to be a
long-term thing or not a long-term thing
but i just want to be with you because
you're a person
i just want to go somewhere and laugh
and be silly and goofy
my brother's super busy with all those
kids i'd love to spend time with them
they don't have time right now
that hurts it does it sucks let's go get
tacos
i'm gonna meet some people at my local
whatever and that's hard right now i
know
i'm gonna be intentional about being
around people who think differently than
i do
and maybe believe differently than i do
i'm gonna be intentional about
diversifying my friend groups
in hopes of just meeting different
people because i have something of value
to give
and it doesn't feel that way because i
reached out i doubled down on my brother
and he said no
but man taking a vet who's about to be
deployed with little kids
and absorbing that as something that's
about you is not is not fair
it's not fair to you it's not fair to
him that's not a signal of your
relationship that signal that somebody's
in the middle of a hurricane right now
and they don't need or desire your
support right now and that's okay
go to the next brother or sister go to
all the brothers and sisters
and also sometimes we just get rejected
and i wish there was a nicer way to
be around that sometimes people just say
i don't want i don't like you i don't
want to be around you
that particularly hurts when it's your
brother or sister i don't think that's
what's happening here but
sometimes we just fly get rejected
sometimes our friends just disappear
sometimes we have to call and say i'm
sorry but sometimes we have to look in
the mirror and say am i somebody who's
judging other people
we have to look in the mirror and say am
i hard to be around am i tough i don't
think i
am am i and maybe ask some of your other
brothers and sisters
am i hard to be around am i annoying are
there things about me that aren't great
the thing about my buddy who's staying
with me today over the years of our
20-25 year of friendship man he's told
me hey dude you're not cool
when you do this this was not funny you
thought this was all silly and goofy
wasn't good he holds me accountable
and it's hard to hear but also helps me
become better
better person better man better dad
better husband better friend
so it sounds like you're just grieving
and i hope you'll grieve i hope you'll
just say this sucks
but i also hope you're not going to
internalize this and that you will risk
relationship you'll
risk love you'll risk going out and
finding somebody else again because
you've got stuff to give
and your love is worthy of being
received so thank you so much for that
hard call kate i just can hear the
heartbreak in your in your voice
and um i hope you will continue to risk
on relationships
not brothers and sister relationships
but risk on hard relationships where
folks don't owe you anything
and they just want to be with you
because you're you so blessings to you
kate
holler back in 30 days i want you to
know in a month or two i want to know
how
reaching out is going i want to know how
you ra
rallying around with a brother or sister
or two that you trust and saying what is
it is it something is it me
am i frustrating and um
i want to know how you're growing
learning to risk all right let's take
one more call let's go to
becca in seattle becca what is happening
how are we doing
good how are you good good good how can
i help this morning
all right so my husband is in the navy
and he's going on deployment soon
we've got a year and a half old daughter
and
um i'm one of those people i'm scared of
the dark i'm scared of everything
and so we were gonna we have security
systems outside of our house
and then i was thinking about getting a
security camera for inside of our house
so if i'm upstairs and something happens
during the night i can just look at the
camera downstairs right
didn't you watch that movie what was uh
james what was that movie paranormal act
yeah paranormal activity didn't you
watch that no
i don't watch games no cameras in the
house you know what's gonna be on those
things
all right so you you got cameras outside
everywhere you're terrified
um and now you just want to be total
terrified all the time 24 7
and be able to see everything all right
so what's your question
so my question is my husband said that
he wanted access
to the camera inside the house while
he's on deployment right
okay just to be able to check in on us
to make sure we're okay
but and he was saying for like if he has
a bad day and he's not able to talk to
us
he just wants to look at the camera and
see that we're okay and then kind of go
about his day right
and that's cool but i don't want him to
check in on us and me have a bad day
and like see me frustrated and see me
upset or see me crying or see me
something like that
and then just make his day worse and
because i don't want to feel like i
failed him you know i want him to to
know that we're doing okay like i can
have my moments of being sad or whatever
but i just don't want him to check in on
us
and see me upset or see me
not doing a good job while he's on
deployment
becca you're awesome can i tell you that
[Laughter]
you're rad dude for real so you when you
told him that what did he say
i have a feeling i know what he said
because he's awesome too but what did he
say
he said that he understood and that i'm
not gonna fail him
that i'm allowed to have bad days but
that just being
even if we're upset like even if he sees
us happy
and sees us playing then that'll give
him what he needs to get through the day
or even if he just sees me sitting on
the couch by the fireplace reading a
book like
that's what he would need to get through
the day and that's cool like i'm happy
that i hope we have good days right like
that's what i'm hoping for
but i'm just scared if he looks at it
twice and both times i'm having a hard
time
i just i don't want it to be more
trouble than it's worth i just don't
want to make it worse
so here's what you got becca that's
pretty cool
you have a husband that doesn't like
doesn't love
that isn't in love with a fantasy or a
mirage
he's in love with an entire person
he's in love with the good stuff the bad
stuff
the weird hair you have on your back the
yeah
the the weird whatever
the you look different than when you
start dating the
time you get the zit he's in love with
all of you
and when he's overseas
yes it would be cool to just have
glamour shots
done up all day 24 7 so when he happens
to beam in
from his bunk and his little tablet and
he can look in
as just a seeing eye on the people that
he loves the most
in the whole wide world the reason he's
doing all this this extraordinary
service
yeah it'd be cool to be all glammed up
and
but man he's a guy that also wants to
see his wife have tears
that's gonna tell him that you miss him
that's gonna tell him that you matter to
him
yeah and he loves all of you
and so here's the thing i think house
cameras are crazy
i don't have any house cameras um
i may get them someday um i like to live
in the illusion that i don't want to
know
if my house is being stormed by
stormtroopers i just prefer to just go
quietly in the night and so be it
i super prefer you gotta watch
paranormal activity dude that movie's a
trip
so i super prefer not looking over at my
whatever camera and seeing some demon
staring at me that would suck
um but if you i'm a fighter you're a
what
i'm a fighter i am too pissed already
i'm a fighter oh
trust me dude we're armed to the gills i
just don't want to see you coming man so
we're yeah we're good
um but yeah it's not an open invitation
i just
i'm also weird i don't want people
hacking into my house cameras and all
that kind of stuff
but here's the deal if you and your
husband are camera people
and he has said i love you and i love
all of you and i want to check in
and he gives you peace then be fully
human and fully present
and i can imagine a scenario where that
kind of technology allows you
and your kids to leave notes and
pictures
it also allows him to see you crying and
being fully
a person and it allows him to see you
laughing
you can set up dates where you dance in
the living room
uh that sounded super weird not that
kind of dance but like a slow dance
right
um and you can have imaginary dance
dates
whatever dude i'm getting creepy now but
whatever that's gonna be
um i could see them in the booth it's
just getting down a dark road here i
wasn't trying to be that kind of dancing
he's a military guy i want him to bomb
my house or something but
um and here's the deal how many cameras
i'm not gonna see him coming if he gets
mad at me but um
dude i think it's a beautiful thing and
i think the pressure you feel to be
perfect
the pressure you feel to um
perpetuate a fantasy for him is
exhausting for you
it's tiring and i think you would give
him some peace of mind if you just wept
openly and you told him i'm gonna really
miss the hell out of you
and i'm proud of you for serving our
country and i'm proud of you for the dad
and husband that you are i'm really
really gonna miss you
and then you all hug regularly i think
that he's gonna
fall deeper in love with you the more he
gets to know you and if he gets to see
you crying gets to see us
smash in a glass because you're angry or
just see the kitchen or wreck or
whatever you're worried about
um he's gonna remember the woman that he
loves
becca and seattle washington he's gonna
remember you
yeah and so man if y'all are all good
with demons in the house and seeing them
i say camera
up family that's going to be rad and
to the veterans who are deploying this
is the second deployment call we've
taken today
man hug tightly before you go
write letters make sure that you stay
connected and
safe travels and i'm so grateful for
your service i'm grateful for each one
of you who sacrifice yourself and your
families
and comfort to make sure that we all
have
our families together too so becca thank
you so much for that call
as we wrap up today's show we're gonna
leave you with
it's not the best song ever i'm just
gonna put it out there it's not the
greatest song ever it's not
but in the grunge era a few songs
emerged
that we can all just say it was pretty
much the greatest song ever right
so in 1992 we had sound garden we had
nirvana we had all these guys that were
just
destroying the 80s metal landscape that
they had built
so so concretely on firm foundations of
musical
extraordinary extraordinariness that's
not a word i just made that up
we had let's let's back that up the
grunge folks came in and destroyed my
80s metal bands that's what freaking
happened
and so the sound gardens and the pearl
jams and the nirvana's
the allison chains yes they're
incredible songwriters yes they changed
music forever
yes they took the kids who were partying
and just trying to have a good time
and we reminded us all how dreary and
awful everything is
those were good those were good but one
band that didn't get the credit they
deserved
showed up in 1992 they did their album
did go triple platinum because it was
incredible
it's called grave dancers union in 1992
soul asylum shows up
and drops this gentle quiet song that
ended up
changing people's lives changing
people's hearts
it's called runaway train and it went
like this
call you up in the middle of the night
like a firefly without a light
you were there like a blow torch burning
i was a key that could use a little
turning
so tired that i couldn't even sleep so
many secrets i couldn't keep
promised myself i wouldn't weep one more
promise
i couldn't keep can you help me remember
how to smile
make it somehow all seem worthwhile how
on earth did i get so
jaded life's mystery seems so faded
i can go where no one else can go and i
know what no one else knows and here i
am just drowning in the rain with a
ticket for a runaway train
[Music]
runaway train never going back wrong way
on a one-way track seems like i should
be getting somewhere somehow i'm neither
here nor there
if you are listening to this and you
feel like you are on the other end of a
wrong way the other end of a one-way
track
call somebody call somebody
this is the dr john dolone's show